well this is a special experiment for
the pft pm podcast who knows how long
it's actually going to last we're going
to try it for today i'm down in the barn
and it's actually kind of cold in the
barn i have a crackling fire in the
background you may hear it you can't see
it because it's behind the camera but
this is where i hang out every other
night or thereabouts to get away from
the craziness that we've all been
dealing with during this pandemic so i
figured i'd bring you down here for
today's edition of pftp i'm going to try
to keep it simple today though this is
the first time that we're doing the
pftpm podcast from the barn had some
minor technical issues to get ironed out
but we'll see how it goes maybe this
will become a new staple of the pft
experience and maybe we'll try different
shots so you can see different parts of
the barn there isn't much you can see
right now this is one of the main seats
to sit and enjoy the four tv screens
that are up on the wall i've got my side
car here where i'll keep an ashtray a
cigar a beverage i got some awesome kiss
coasters if you see that that's the
first kiss album if you're not familiar
with that i've got like 12 to 15 of
these kiss coasters that have
they they have they have had plenty of
wear and tear here rock and roll over
awesome cover art if you recall that
album or if you've ever seen it before
or if you're young you have no idea what
i'm talking about all right so uh let's
get right to it then
let's go ahead and do what we always do
on a friday pf tpm answer some of your
questions i got my little mobile laptop
down here i got some pft stickers i need
to put one on that thing although free
advertising for apple payout when you
want a podcast podcast sponsorship here
there's your big there's your big apple
see that
payment all right time for some of your
questions pftp and posse what do you
think about playing games with no fans
in the nfl offering fans the ability to
interact and support one of the teams
online allow fans to earn by tokens it
can be redeemed strategically during the
game to increase fake crowd noise piped
in by the league that's a question that
comes via josh the blaze i like the
creativity i don't see it ever happening
i think that what we're gonna have to
accept is
when they play these games with no fans
if that's how it plays out and it will
not surprise me at all if that's what
happens until there's a vaccine i can't
imagine stadiums full of fans or
stadiums with any fans i mean maybe they
can have very limited fan presence maybe
you can have people who are screened
ahead of time as being virus free maybe
they sit in the suites but can you
really imagine 70 000 people crammed
together like they used to be i don't
think that's gonna happen george kittle
pointed out during the interview earlier
if you were listening to it that even
though they're giving up home field
advantage at levi's stadium he's happy
to go to places like seattle and not
have home field advantage for the home
team there not have to go silent count
not have to strain to hear what's going
on when they're trying to run their
offense so it balances out it's a
different reality there will be no home
field advantage per se for any teams so
really the teams that don't have home
field advantage will be the ones that
get the advantage like the chargers
right they never have a home field
advantage so it evens out that way any
team that plays well on the road any
team that doesn't have that deafening
crowd at home
that team is going to be better off than
the teams that maybe rely upon that
noise that energy to get them going when
they are playing games at home and for
teams like seattle known for having that
incredible home field advantage from
crowd noise they're going to have to
find other ways to win their home games
because they're going to be able to wipe
that 12 off the board during these games
that go without fans if that's how it
all plays out and look let me just say
this nobody knows what's going to happen
anybody who tells you they know what's
going to happen is either stupid or
lying or a little bit or a lot of both i
think the best thing to say about any
type of football high school college pro
we just don't know and the virus is
going to set the timeline and anybody
who's suggesting that college football
has a strong conviction there was a
report from chef yesterday people in and
around college football have a strong
conviction there's going to be games i
don't care
the virus sets the schedule and the best
thing to say is that we plan to play the
best thing to say is we're planning for
everything and we have a plan for
whatever happens and ultimately the
virus is going to set the schedule
all right let's see what we have now
here
pftp and posse it's my wife's birthday
today what are some of your best
birthday memories with your wife
and of your wife's
birthday well
look i i i don't know i'd have to sit
and really think about it because i'm an
adult and once you're an adult the
birthday isn't as big of a deal as it
once was other holidays yes birthday
what does jerry seinfeld say in the
episode where he's trying not to be
funny because george is concerned that
the girl that he's met will think jerry
is funny and then like jerry better than
george
birthdays are a reminder that we're
another year older and we're another
year closer to our demise and also
we've spent another 365 days on the
planet not getting any closer to the
things that we're trying to do so
birthdays suck is basically what i'm
saying and i say that as somebody who
has a birthday coming up in fewer than
two months and i don't want a happy
birthday i just want to move past my
birthday and on to the next day so happy
birthday pft pm posse's way next
question
delete
rao aka at leapers 500 how do we deal
with the reflexive
politicization of everything that
happens we seem to be unable to process
data in any other algorithm we can't
hold folks accountable do right and work
hard for everything it's first about
opposing your enemies probably one that
i shouldn't have read because
everyone wants me to stick to football
except when they agree with me see
that's how it works
if i talk about something from a
political perspective that you agree
with you're fine with it if it comes
from a perspective you disagree with i
should stick to football
and this is kind of where we are right
now even as we deal with this pandemic
we've got red state blue state we've got
one corner we've got the other corner
and everyone's processing their
information taking the news through the
prism of what they believe which is
asinine if you ask me we should be
deferring to the experts we should be
accepting what the experts have to say
but one of the realities here and i'm
trying to be apolitical as i say this
one of the realities of having leaders
that
try to tear down every institution that
we have relied upon in the past when the
time comes to rely upon those
institutions for information that may
save our lives we're inclined not to
listen to those institutions and that's
probably all i should say about that for
now what else do we have how about this
another one from leapfrog's 500. is cam
newton in danger of not finding a seat
in the mad musical chairs of this
particular dance i don't know that he
doesn't find a seat
i just think that he may have to wait
now if he could get a physical right now
a team like the chargers would
presumably bring him in right now to
give him a full physical see how the
foot's doing see how the ankle's doing
see how the shoulder is doing remember
last year he was breaking in a new
throwing motion at her about the time
that he injured his foot so there are
multiple concerns when it comes to
checking out the health of cam newton
but given where we are right now no one
has the opportunity to have their
doctors give camo physical so everybody
has to wait and wait may be the key for
cam and also a guy like james winston
peter king and i were talking about this
today because this is going to be such a
crazy season
and because when it's time to get back
to football it could be some guys maybe
aren't in the kind of shape they need to
be in maybe they break down maybe they
get injured
if you're jameis winston or cam newton
and the only opportunities out there to
go be someone's backup maybe you just
wait for somebody to get injured the
phone to ring and you have the
opportunity to walk right in and be the
starter look what happened last year if
cam newton or jameis winston were
available to the pittsburgh steelers
come week two of the 2019 season do you
not call
cam newton or jameis winston in lieu of
handing the ball to mason rudolph now
the problem is a lot of teams will say
we're going to go next man up we're
going to go with the guy who knows the
offense but this year that gap isn't
going to be as big between the stranger
who may be more physically gifted and
the guy who's on the inside who knows
the offense because everything's going
to be truncated what you know about the
offense is going to be less extensive
than what you would know in other years
so it very well may be that the best
play for cam newton is to wait i
personally think that a team like the
chargers or even the dolphins need to
pounce on cam newton asap
even without the ability to give him a
physical because based on the videos
i've seen online he looks fine to me now
i understand you may be taking the risk
there may be structure the contract to
protect you against that risk but at the
same time this guy when healthy is one
of the best quarterbacks in the nfl have
we forgotten that he was the mvp of the
league in 2015 have we forgotten that
have we forgotten what a force he is how
big and strong and mobile and fast and
everything we're looking for in a
quarterback and yes that brings along
the risk of injury but at the same time
if he stays healthy you're gonna have a
better team if he stays stays healthy
you're going to have a better
quarterback better than tyrod taylor for
the charters better than ryan
fitzpatrick for the dolphins and i think
those are the two teams to keep an eye
on unless and until there's an injury
that is suffered and remember
the quarterbacks out there aren't going
to sit around and watch bowling and eat
pork rinds they're going to be working
out and they're going to be working out
in places that aren't their team
facilities and you never know what's
going to happen you find a high school
field there's a rock somewhere that you
step on there's a divot in the field
just some fluke thing happens step on a
sprinkler whatever the case may be
as guys work out on their own and surely
they will there's a chance somebody's
going to get injured and uh that risk is
going to be there throughout this crazy
time where teams can't get together at
their own facilities all the more reason
to maybe wait if you're cam newton and
jameis winston for that injury to happen
and maybe the door to open
libras 500 has one more before we move
on to others
why does brandon cooks keep getting
shipped around like a side of beef
is it that he's just good enough to want
but not good enough to play out of his
salary good for him either way yeah this
is a guy who was the 20th overall pick i
believe in 2014 by the saints 2017
traded for a first round pick to the
patriots 2018 traded for a first round
pick to the rams who immediately signed
in sight unseen to a big money contract
and paid him
40.54 million dollars for only two years
of service first year 1200 receiving
yards first year why
in the third quarter of the super bowl
with the rams down three nothing and
jared goff held onto the ball for too
long and didn't get it there accurately
enough for cooks to make the play the
ball was broken up by i think jason
mccordy it was one of the 40s i think it
was jason mccordy but then last year
less than 600 yards receiving for
brandon cook's missed a couple of games
with his fourth concussion since super
bowl 52 remember super bowl 52 he took
that wicked head shot from malcolm
jenkins wow cooks was still playing for
the patriots jenkins obviously with the
eagles at the time four concussions
since that one so that one plus three
others i can count and that's another
reason to be concerned so i i personally
think
that
at some level bill o'brien
reacting to the very intense criticism
of
the decision to trade deandre hopkins
criticism from fans from media maybe
some blowback from the team some
frustration from quarterback to sean
watson to the point where people are
speculating that come 2021 watson won't
even be with the texans anymore maybe
this move was about
getting people off of bill o'brien's
back the fans the media and watson
whereas the reality is this and this is
a great point peter king made today on
pft live
with that 57th overall pick in the draft
that the texans gave up to get cooks
you could get a pretty good receiver
this year eric decosta the ravens gm
said thursday he thinks in round five
you can find a starting receiver that's
how deep this class is so you give up
pick number 57 for cooks
that pick may end up turning out to be
a much better receiver and a guy that
you're going to have cheaper and a guy
that comes in with a clean bill of
health without the injury history
without the concussion problem and it
could be that there'll be a backfire
there'll be a boomerang there'll be
people like me two weeks from tonight
who see who's there at pick number 57
which receivers the texans could have
had and it makes it worse
if the rams take a receiver with that
57th pick because then it's set up
apples to apples cooks versus whoever
the rams take with the pick they got
from bill o'brien
risky move by the texans to say the
least an expensive move by the rams they
had to pay a 4 million roster bonus just
to hold on to cooks beyond the 30th day
of march actually it was earned probably
the third day in the league year but it
was payable the end of march either way
four million out just to hang on to
cooks long enough to get that 57th
overall pick in the draft and as i
mentioned 44
40.54 million
for two years of cook services that's
over 20 million a year and all due
respect to cooks he did not play like a
20 million dollar a year receiver
terry gensler wants to know if we can
get a nut sticking to football segment
at the end i already kind of straight in
that direction i'll have a few things to
say about what's going on in the world
before we wrap this thing up
a red zone out otherwise known as tom
marshall a good friend of ours from
across the atlantic ocean how will
players who have earnings tied to
off-season workouts be paid there's
roughly 36 million in
off-season workout bonuses out there for
veteran players this typically isn't a a
facet of the rookie contract it becomes
very common in veteran deals mike
garofolo had a breakdown last week of
who makes what
zadari smith in the packers i think 750
000
for workout bonuses last i heard the
league in the union continuing to figure
out what it's going to take to qualify
for those workout bonuses i was told
over the weekend that the nfl wants
beyond the participation in meetings via
technologies like zoom which is how
we're doing this today from the barn
they're going to want guys to wear heart
monitors when they work out they're
going to want zoom monitoring and
supervision of their workouts so they
can check the box and know that the guys
are doing what they have to do but some
guys just don't have the equipment
what are they going to do spend 10 grand
to go out and buy the stuff so they can
have a gym at their homes some guys live
in condos or apartments where it's
almost impossible to do that so it's
going to be a challenge to get guys in a
position where they can earn the money
and
some guys may just not be able to do it
whose fault has it been how are they
supposed to anticipate that they're
going to need to have the equipment in
their home necessary to do what they're
supposed to do but i think it's going to
be driven by individual determinations
of what guys need to do what guys are
capable of doing and it's not going to
be the easiest thing to draw the
motivation to do we asked george kittle
about that earlier
for him
he'll wake up in the morning and run
through a wall no matter what because he
knows it's going to make him better at
football and he loves football so he'll
do whatever it takes to be good at
football not everybody's like george
kittle there's plenty of people are
gonna have a hard time finding the
motivation necessary to do what needs to
be done so that is something that needs
to be considered as they determine how
players will earn their workout bonuses
maximum overdrive or more accurately
maximus overdrive will there be another
attempt at the spring football league
they all have failed some way somehow is
there a formula for success well
i don't know
you know going into the xfl season my
take was
no matter how much i try to make myself
care about spring football i don't i
just don't i can't get excited about
spring football i don't care about
spring football
i try to but i don't now i watch the xfl
every weekend that it was on i watched
the aaf last year every weekend that it
was on it's on tv it's great background
noise while i'm working out or not
working out but working or working out i
was doing it well while doing both
i just kept it on during that six hour
window on saturdays and sundays i need
to see all of it but i saw plenty of it
and i'll watch it if it's on and people
were watching it now the ratings started
high and we saw them slide down as the
season went on and who knows what was
going to happen with the xfl ratings
once they got up against the
ncaa men's conference
championship weekend against the first
weekend of march madness the second
weekend the third weekend etc those
numbers i think we're going to keep
dropping baseball returns numbers keep
dropping so i think it's going to be a
challenge to get a sustained audience
the question is how much wherever the
floor is how much does it take to
justify the endeavor and the key is
going to be legalized gambling people
taking to spring football as a way to
provide the platform for betting but the
pandemic i think sets the clock back on
all of that for several years i think
the economy is going to have to get back
to normal the sports betting industry is
going to have to recover from what's
happened this year and once that happens
maybe there's an opening for spring
football and look i'm not saying i
endorse this but one of the things i've
been saying for the past few years
i think there is an appetite and a
thirst for
old school football for football like
they used to play in the 80s and 90s and
if you don't know what i'm talking about
go to youtube and pull up any of the
games from the 80s and the 90s that are
available there for you to watch and if
you really want to see old school go
back to the 70s there's a clip floating
around of
mel blunt i believe
lifting cliff branch off the ground and
basically pile driving him
and it is so
violent it is so stunning to see
especially in light of today's standards
for football what makes it even more
stunning
right after the pile drive
an official walks into the frame very
nonchalantly like hey that happens all
the time no big deal so i'm not saying i
agree with it i'm not saying it's right
but what i'm saying is
if there's somebody out there who's
willing to spend the money willing to
take the chance willing to drop all the
agreements in a way that the waivers are
in place and everybody signs off on what
they're getting into a football league
that brings back football the way it
used to be can find
can find a an audience and can make
money just like ufc does if you've ever
watched ufc it is shockingly brutal and
i think ufc would be shut down if as
many people watch that as watch the nfl
and so
you know if it's almost like an
alternative football league that is old
school if it just was kind of a niche
thing that that the people who would be
flabbergasted by it never really pay
attention to it could survive it could
thrive and i think it could find an
audience and it could be successful but
i think that is the only way to make
spring football work giving somebody
giving that fan base giving those people
out there who are looking for football
the way it used to be played and you
know there are plenty of people out
there who feel that way you're giving
them that product even if it's not
during football season all right let's
see what else we have here
tyler fernes with the draft being
virtual would you recommend that the
time for each selection go up to 15
minutes to better allow for trades and
to ensure we don't get clock fiasco's
but i said this on pft live this week i
mean it's the ultimate captive audience
right
where where are we going on the first
night of the draft where are we going on
the second night of the draft so what if
it's a little bit longer go back to 15
minutes now here's the thing
if you don't start until 8 o'clock i
remember those first rounds back when
they did 15 minutes taking like six
hours so they do need to move along uh
from the standpoint of having a tv show
that people will watch but
look i
i don't have a problem with more time
i i
i just don't like the
the conce i feel like the concern about
technological issues is overblown and i
don't want to say it's phony i just
think a lot of people are confused a lot
of people are leery
and and and that's fine you're used to
being in a room with everyone you you
know and everything you need and now
you're relying upon technology to fill
those gaps
i can understand why there's some
hesitation but i think if they do a dry
run they're going to do a mock draft i
think people will get a better feel for
what it's gonna take to get their picks
in on time and to understand it's
different but it's not impossible to
figure out how to do it and there are
redundancies in place to prevent any
type of of a potential uh
debacle that would uh screw up a team's
opportunity to get the player that they
want all right let's see what else we
have here
huh el marco lives whereas james going
to end up stick it out until a starter
gets injured in pre-season that's
exactly what we were saying earlier wait
for somebody to start if you think
you're a starter and no one's offering
you a starter job then you just wait now
you're taking the chance that no one's
going to get injured that no one's going
to call or if someone does get injured
they're going to treat you like they
treat colin kaepernick and just look for
someone else let's get through 50 109
yards last year eighth highest all time
only four human beings have thrown for
more yards in a season than jameis
winston has done because some of them
have done it multiple times
drew brees ben roethlisberger tom brady
peyton manning not bad company when you
look at the list of the all-time top
single season passing yard performances
start looking at those names
there's a lot of hall of famers
in that list there's a lot of guys who
have gone on to do great great things
once they've checked the box on a 5 000
yard season which is what jameis winston
did and yes he also checked the box on a
30 interception season that's the
problem but i think that teams could do
a hell of a lot worse than jameis
winston and if an injury happens i think
he's a guy you bring in you know sims
and i are all over the idea of the 49ers
bringing in james winston because we
both agree that in
kyle shanahan's system it's very
simplified it's very basic and you just
go a b c d through the steps of what
shanahan wants you to do there isn't a
whole lot of quarterback independent
thought in there that may make it less
likely that jameis winston
has one of those moments where he almost
has an out-of-body experience where he
tries to do more than he's physically
capable of doing so i think that makes a
ton of sense all right let's see what
else we have here uh scrolling scrolling
sources from new era cap and lids have
told me there is a new raiders logo that
will be revealed at the draft anything
you can add don't have much besides them
saying we were told not to reveal until
the pick is in i haven't heard anything
about a new raiders logo the raiders
logo is one of the most classic and
iconic in the nfl now maybe there's some
way they've worked in the word vegas to
the logo but with all these teams
changing uniforms and this is where
chris sims would chide me for being an
old man
i like the classic looks i like the
block numbers i like the old uniforms i
like the packers i like the raiders i
like the cowboys i like the uniforms
that stand the test time look at the
colts very basic but they never change
right block numbers white and blue and
nothing fancy and i knew the moment nike
got involved because we saw what nike
was doing in college football the moment
mikey got involved with nfl uniforms we
were going to see this revolving door
teams with new uniforms every two or
three years the browns it seems like
they have new uniforms every few years
and the falcons have bounced around with
different uniforms and the jaguars with
different uniforms and now the
buccaneers have had two uniforms since
nike took over and i look
there's there's a strong financial
incentive to have new uniforms because
then people go out and buy the new
jerseys but i i'm i'm a fan of keeping
it if it works if you have a look it
works look at the cheese the chief's
gonna change your uniforms hell no if
you have a look that works you keep it
keep it year to year that's part of what
fans identify with and uh i i'd be i'd
be disappointed if the raiders change
their logo because they have one of the
best ones in all the sport
dean osborne 42 here's a football
question somewhere in the world you
haven't visited yet but really want
to go to one day well you know what we
were in the process of planning a trip
to london and then to italy
this spring and summer um that ain't
happening and who knows when that's
gonna happen hopefully it happens at
some point in the next five years we
really want to get over to london to
visit with our fans there the folks who
have enjoyed
pft live on sky sports have been very
antsy and very anxious over the past
month or so while we've been off if you
haven't heard we're back as of thursday
live local time 12 to 2 p.m that's in
london uk and ireland we'd love to go
visit our friends there and i i'm from
italy my folks are from italy
kind of they're they're first generation
neither were born in italy but their
parents were so it's close enough i'm
second generation and i i kind of know
where i want to go the places i want to
see the places where my people are from
and we've been talking about doing it
but that's not going to happen anytime
soon
all right uh what else do we have here
um
dean osborne 42 does tom brady's boring
interview with howard stern mean no
possibility of an announcing gig should
he want it when his playing days are
over since he can't be trusted if he
can't understand anything much of
interest i think he opened up more than
he ever did and ever will with howard
stern
and i think whether or not you're candid
during an interview is different from
whether or not you're going to be
insightful or
interesting if you're a broadcaster
there's been no reason to think tom
brady wants to do it but when the money
that's being thrown around is getting up
toward 20 million dollars per year i
don't know maybe brady gives it a try
but remember this brady's idol joe
montana suck all due respect joe we love
you as a football player you were not
good as a broadcaster and his coach bill
walsh
rest in peace bill walsh was not good as
a broadcaster either so just because
you're a genius just because you're a
great quarterback it doesn't mean you're
going to be a great broadcaster i think
peyton manning definitely will be when
he decides to do it i i'm not sold on
whether or not tom brady has the chops
to do it and i'm not sold on whether or
not he has the desire to do it he wants
to go all in with that tb12 project at
some point i saw today that they're
going to open a location in tampa gee
there's a shock new york la he's in the
process of expanding that brand but
here's the thing if you have a big
platform with an nfl broadcast that's a
way to
to
keep people coming to the tv 12
facilities so who knows maybe that's
something that tom brady will do if and
when he retires from the nfl and i
should say when but with him hell you
got to say if because you never know if
he's actually going to retire or if he's
just going to keep playing as long as he
possibly can scrolling through here to
see what else we have
uh
nets
jets fan has a question about otas and
off-season workouts but also games so
it's a broader question that we haven't
addressed earlier
will the nfl be responsible for paying
players for cancelled otas and or games
look
i saw something from ben vaughn of the
boston globe that suggested if there's
no gains players won't be paid and he
pointed to the fact
that the nfl cba doesn't have what they
call a force major clause
if anything the absence of a forced
major clause in the nfl cba
would require the league to pay the
players if there are no games we wrote
something about that a few weeks ago the
nba talking about not paying players the
nba has in its collective bargaining
agreement a forced major clause an act
of god clause a clause that says in the
event of an epidemic if we can't
play we don't pay you the nba has that
the nfl does not either in the cba or in
the standard player contract there is
nothing there that says if some act of
god if some
weather emergency if there is war if
there is pandemic or epidemic we don't
pay you if we can't play the games
that's just not there so
i
and the nfl is never going to agree to
this the nfl will fight this because
there's too much money at stake and i
had one source tell me the league's
position would be
if they play
no games they don't have to pay the
players anything if they play even one
game they have to pay the players
everything which makes no sense to me
but again i i understand why the league
would be trying to stake out something
like that where their position is that
we don't
play you don't get paid
because they're going to want the union
to go along with whatever efforts are
identified to play the game because
that's the union's leverage right the
union can sit back and say
we get paid
if we don't play
so
you have to figure out a way that we're
going to play
that
we're happy with and we're comfortable
with
and if we don't like it we're not going
to agree to it
if we don't like the idea that you're
going to take everybody to some remote
facility and we're all going to live
there for four months no we're not going
to do that if you want us to do it you
need to make another concession and you
can't just say these are the rules this
is how we're going to play
and if you don't show up and play you
don't get paid
the union's going to have to be on board
with this and i think the union has a
much stronger position than people
realize because there's the doughnut
hole in the cba and the standard player
contract that does not allow the league
to say to the players sorry
no gains no pay that's something to keep
an eye on and let me tell you
that makes it all the more likely the
nfl identifies a way to play these games
even if the stadiums are empty the nfl
is going to do what it has to do because
if the nfl has to pay these players to
not
uh or
if they have to pay the players to not
play i knew i'd get there eventually if
they have to pay the players to not play
you're going to bankrupt some of these
teams that's all the money going out no
money coming in and that's the other
thing to keep in mind too what the hell
is this season going to do the salary
cap next year because the salary cap in
any given year is the product of the
revenue from the prior year if the
revenue just disappears this year or if
the the ticket revenue is gone but the
tv revenue is there
it's going to reduce what's available
and you're gonna have salary caps that
plot next year and you got contracts
that are premised on you know a salary
cap that keeps growing and growing and
growing what kind of moves are teams
going to have to make to save cap space
next season i got to cut some big-name
players or renegotiate some contracts
and they'll wish that they had contracts
that were tied to cap percentages that's
something i've been advocating for years
for star players under the assumption
that the cap was going to keep going up
and up and up and because of that
assumption teams didn't want to do it
they're going to be wishing they'd done
it if the cap goes down the way that it
could next year but all the more reason
to find a way to play the games and
if there isn't college football if there
isn't high school football it's all the
more reason for the nfl to find a way to
broaden its weekend from thursday to
sunday to monday to throw in friday
night and three windows on saturday
because if we're at the point where fans
can't be in the stands if we're at the
point where high school football doesn't
get played if we're at the point where
college football can't be played that
means that we're going to be home a lot
in the fall and that means that people
will flock to those windows as we have a
friday night game a saturday at one
o'clock eastern game a saturday at 4 25
eastern game a saturday night game do it
again sunday monday night i mean that's
going to become the anchor of the week
for most sports fans that's going to be
it if that's what happens now other
sports may start popping up again with
no fans but
who knows the nfl i believe is going to
move heaven and earth to play its games
and maybe can backfill the vacancies
created by no high school football no
college football we'll see how that all
plays out all right uh just scrolling
through here to see
if there's anything else that uh here's
a question from brock26 who brought 26
apparently hasn't been paying attention
to what's been going on with our radio
show or non-radio show wants to know
he's the nbc sports radio app no more
i've been trying to listen live the last
two weeks and get nothing yeah what
happened is
um
as of march 31
westwood won which operated nbc sports
radio nbc sports radio wasn't something
that nbc sports radio ran nbc sports
essentially licensed the name to
westwood 1 which created the network and
distributed the content
and westwood one decided march 31 that
it was no longer going to to televise or
not televise
radio ties i'm sounding like sims now no
longer broadcast the network and that
decision was made before the pandemic
this is not a pandemic decision this is
early march march 2nd i got the phone
call from jack silver with westwood one
who informed me that the radio network
was going to go uh silent on march 31
and that's what they decided to do so
what's happened with us
we still are on nbcsn with a very
different clock the radio clock very
restrictive a couple of hard outs every
hour more break time and created some
clunky things on tv where we take a
break we come back for like a minute and
then have another break and then come
back for a radio and tv segment then
take another break and have a tv segment
now it's just tv segments across the
board the show is on sirius xm211 it's
on the tunein app and also you can get
the podcast as well so that is the
reason why the nbc sports radio app is
no longer working which tells me i i
need to do a better job of getting the
word out we thought everybody knew but
apparently not everyone is aware of that
all right uh that's it it's 4 20 p.m by
the way eastern so uh
go ahead and do what you do at 4 20 but
before before we go look
it's been a long five or six weeks
for everyone and i remember sitting in
this chair
five weeks ago tonight and and watching
the news
and that was the day the president was
at the cdc in atlanta
and i just remember getting the sense
watching his comments
having it all sink in understanding how
this ball and it doesn't take i think a
genius to see where the ball was moving
and where this was all going i remember
five weeks ago tonight just being
as down in the dumps as i've been in a
very long time because i knew
what was coming
and we've seen it come over the last
five weeks now
there's reason to believe it's not going
to be as bad as we thought because
we reacted the way we did with the
extreme measures to keep people at home
and i i fully expect that at some point
the coveted truthers out there will say
see it was no big deal we shouldn't have
done everything we did well the reason
it wasn't as big of a deal as it was
going to be is because people did the
things they were supposed to do and i
hope people are smart enough to figure
that out but at this point in our
existence i'm not ready to assume anyone
is smart enough to figure out anything
that would cause them to deviate from
their predetermined and pre-existing
beliefs all that said it has been a long
road for all of us and i think all we
can do
is just keep
going i've used this example over and
over again we are climbing a mountain we
have no idea where the top of the
mountain is so all we can do is focus on
each
additional move right every day you move
your hand a little bit higher you bring
your foot up a little bit higher and you
just hope you don't fall off the
mountain while you're trying to climb to
the top of the thing wherever the top
may be and we have some ideas of where
the top is going to be and it may be
that we kind of reach a shelf that isn't
quite the top but then we keep climbing
and then maybe we reach another plateau
but then we keep climbing and that's the
thing we have to keep in mind there will
be moments where we allow ourselves to
think hey it's over we're back to normal
that's the worst thing we can do it's
not back to normal until there's a
vaccine and the spanish flu of 1918 it
was the third wave that killed the most
people and can't we already see that
happening
a lot of americans who maybe haven't
been following this as closely as they
should maybe don't understand it as well
as they should we haven't had to touch
their lives yet who are kind of
i don't know
nonchalant about all of it there are
plenty of people out there who are still
in that mindset
once they feel like they can go back to
doing the things they do then
it's a breeding ground for the virus to
spread so we have a second wave we have
a third wave and it's going to continue
until we have that vaccine and all we
can do all we can do for ourselves for
our families for our friends for our
colleagues and for each other is just
keep climbing that mountain every day
and believe that there is a top
somewhere and it together we are going
to get that's all we can do and i've
accepted that and hopefully you'll
accept that too and along the way we're
going to try to provide you with
things to talk about that aren't the
coronavirus that aren't all the people
who are dying all the people who are
sick and all the hot spots throughout
the country and throughout the world and
that's our way of contributing to this
effort to get through it
now
if there's football to be played it's a
lot easier for us to give you things to
talk about i i i haven't really given a
lot of thought to how we get through
doing football shows during the months
of football season if there is no
football i'll worry about that when it
happens because again our position isn't
we're planning for football season our
position is we're going to have a plan
for every scenario and if there is no
football season we'll find something to
talk about we'll find something to give
you a diversion and a distraction from
what's going on in the world and we'll
continue to do that it's easy for now
though because the draft is in 13 days
and we'll spend the next two weeks
getting you ready for the draft and
we'll fully immerse in the draft in the
aftermath of all the undrafted free
agents and then at some point in may
we may have to get a little creative
we may have to just try to interview as
many people as we can and find out what
people are doing as they work out on
their own but we'll figure it out and
we'll keep providing you with content
that'll get you through this as we all
climb that mountain one inch at a time
and hopefully at some point get to the
top we'll see you next week with all new
editions of pft live monday through
friday p-f-t-o-t p-f-t-p-m and if you
like pftpm from the barn
maybe we'll try it again at some point
down the road everybody have a good
weekend stay safe be strong and we'll
talk to you on monday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports